Trevor, Devin, welcome
back to the forge.
You've had five days
at your home forges
to work on your finale weapons.
Trevor, how did it go?
It went pretty good.
It was long days,
a lot of hard work.
It's a 115 layer damascus.
Three steels.
The guard is
constructed out of steel
I had left over from the blade.
Great.
Devin, tell the judges
about your blade.
Unfortunately, it's
the second blade I made.
The first one developed
a lot of cracks.
I used a 5160
single steel blade.
It has a bronze guard,
and a brass clamshell.
I feel great.
This is awesome.
Well, gentlemen, your
blades look beautiful,
worthy of hanging on the walls.
However, they still
have to be tested.
Up first, the kill test.
Doug?
The sawback hunting sword.
As the name implies,
it's used for hunting,
to hunt for the kill.
I'm gonna take your weapon
and deliver lethal blows
on this ram carcass.
Trevor, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
My heart is pounding, all
I can think is don't break.
Don't break.
Yes!
All right, Trevor.
First up, the balance of
this weapon is beautiful.
It feels like you
can move with it.
It thrusts, it's sharp, and the
first cut alone, it lacerated
the carcass of the deer.
The second one-- the third
one was pretty much just
to finish it off.
When I grab onto your
handle, it feels comfortable.
I can tell where the edge is.
Now, there's one area
right here where there's
a little bit where the
edge rolled, because it
would hit thick spine.
But overall, your
weapon, sir, will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Devin,
it's your turn.
You ready?
I'm ready.
Let's do this.
Good luck.
Oh, boy.
I feel great.
I feel really excited.
I'm hoping that I can
at least one up him,
and get it in three strikes.
[clattering]
Oh, man!
[sigh]
Dude, I'm sorry.
Well, Devin, first up,
aside from the obvious,
I must say that that's
a beautiful handle.
Thank you.
It feels good in the hand.
Quality stuff.
Your blade broke.
Look at the grain structure.
In your grain structure over
here, it shows that it's rough.
Looks like sands on the beach,
so that's a heat treat issue.
So I really appreciate that you
brought us a beautiful sword,
but it had a critical failure.
It broke.
Devin, I'm just
going to be direct--
your blade has suffered a
catastrophic weapons failure,
and can't continue with testing.
In other words, it
doesn't make the cut,
and I have to ask you to
please leave the forge.
Thank you.
I came in here looking
for the hardest,
craziest challenge I could
get, and I think I got it.
Winning would have been great.
Second place, I'm fortunate.
Fire-- I'm happy with that, too.
It's been one hell of a ride.